Dr. Kevin Cutters, again, we're going over some more of your genetic profile, and this section,
we're going to be talking about glutathione. It won't be on page 9 of your profile,
as this is updated regularly, and I am looking at the practitioner profile here. So,
when we look at your glutathione genes, we've expanded these genes as more data has come out.
There's several that we want to pay closer attention to. Now, what is glutathione?
Glutathione is your main intracellular antioxidant in your body. It's extremely important.
You may be going to a practitioner who's currently giving you glutathione right now. That's not
always a good idea, as you're going to see, as we go over this. So, glutathione is normally recycled
in a pathway in your body. It's oxidized and reduced, so it's recycled and reused in your body,
and it's fed through a specific genetic pathway called your Transalpheration Pathway.
The purpose of glutathione is to get rid of oxidants in your body, oxidizing agents,
so it's a reducer to get rid of these oxidizing agents that's called an antioxidant. Now,
your body needs oxidizing agent for a period of time. It helps kill things, and that's the purpose
of oxidation in your body. However, excess oxidation can cause a lot of problems,
and our diets and exposure to toxins and such can leave a person in a state of hyper-oxidation,
which can lead to cancer and all sorts of things. So, we have to look at these genes. The first
family of genes in the glutathione pathway are the CTH genes right here. The most important,
the most researched of all these family of genes is this top one. Now, this particular person
does not have a defect in there. So, he's got other glutathione CTH defects, but don't know that I
would jump on really supporting this. And, plus again, again, would you give a person straight
glutathione? Typically, I don't hardly ever give straight glutathione. We give precursors,
we support the pathways. So, if you give straight glutathione number one, it's not really readily
absorbed. It's not readily utilized. You want to help the pathway itself. You don't always want to
give an end product. Now, you'll see in some of these, it's really easy to give an end product because
there isn't a negative feedback loop of production. But, on some of them, you don't, and this one is
typically you don't want to give them. The SHMT deep genes in this glutathione pathway, this person
doesn't really have a big problem there, either even though this top one and this bottom one are
more important, you could say. But, still, maybe I wouldn't jump on the glutathione support pathway
with him because you can see his other genes, the GCL genes are really in pretty good shape.
And, the GSS genes are really in fairly good shape, too. Now, he's kind of an abnormally,
as far as my patients go because he's got a lot less problems than a lot of my patients do.
So, these are the genes that we look at with glutathione cycle. And, my report gives you,
hey, you got pretty good function of most glutathione genes with this individual. So, that's really
good news for this person. But, if you look at your report, you might see a lot of twos in here,
a lot of woods, where this person has a lot of blagues. That is why I may have
wanted to support this pathway. Though, it's really important if I make the recommendation for something
like GSH assist. Oh, that's a glutathione product. So, I'm going to start taking my old, which is
just straight glutathione or cystine. There's a reason why I make a recommendation like this,
depending on other pathway defects. Not to get too technical. But, if you have defects in your
CBS pathway, which is weighed out on this chart, weighed out at the bottom of here. But, if you have
CBS defects, you do not want to give cystine and you don't want to give straight glutathione. So,
there's a reason behind the madness when I make a recommendation for somebody just so you know.
So, it's not just tap and stand. So, you have to look at the whole ginormous picture in order to
come up with the recommendations that I come up with. But, I made not even recommend anything for
this particular person. If he had a lot more defects than we may support that, especially on his
symptoms, this person didn't have a lot of symptoms that would warrant it either. All right, that's
glutathione. I hope that helps. Understand, you have to look at the whole pathway. So, we also talk
about glutathione when we talk about the trans-selferation pathway because that's what feeds it.
We also talk about glutathione when we get down here to talk about the SOD detox pathway,
because SOD feeds glutathione. Of this person has a lot of SODG defects, which
isn't going to tell us to do support glutathione, but we have to support the other side of this pathway.
So, it directly, we're supporting glutathione when we support the SOD pathway because they intermingle.
Follow me. I know it gets super complicated, but it's really not that complicated.
So, I'm trying to take the complication out of it. That's why we have these videos.
Keep watching them. I hope they help, and that they're a blessing to you. Bye-bye.